[Music]
let's go
one game we're 21-18 so
20-77 jordan 1900
there have been a lot of requests on
the youtube comments to play to play d4
i hear you
so we're gonna stick with d4 for a
couple of games here c6 so this this
offers us the
possibility of transposing to a karaoke
but we were going to stick to
d4 so we're going to play c4 and
transpose into a slav
this is a slav this is the first time we
face the slav i think in all of our
speed runs so knight f3 is main line we
develop both of our knights this is
standard fairy here black has
a major fork in the road black has a
couple of possible variations of which
a6
is one this is called the chabanenko
variation i think it got popular around
like the 60s or 70s black prepares a
very quick b5 you might have seen min
playing this line
i don't know much about a6 because i
don't really play the slob with white
that much one thing that i've always
played here with white is this move g3
or very catalan
kind of style if you've watched my blitz
games you know that i'm a big fan of
playing g3 in the slot in general i
think it leads to
very dynamic positions
of course this is a pawn sacrifice so
black can take on c4 and we will not try
particularly hard to win that pawn back
immediately so
you have to be
ready to play sacrificial lines if you
want to play this bishop g4
i think is quite dubious can anybody
tell me why or maybe it's a line i'm not
sure but generally in these positions
bishop g4 walks he walks right into 95
yeah 95. so we centralize our knight
and of course you should also be aware
of the move queen b3
which in many cases comes with great
effect but before we do any of that
well we we
should probably develop our bishop to g2
but then black plays e6 and solidifies
his position
so the other option is to play the
immediate queen b3 and try to go out go
go for black's throat
you know i actually like the look of
queen b3
i actually like the look of queen b3 i'm
hoping for b5 here what min does in
these positions is play this very weird
oh b6
uh
that has to be inaccurate
that has to be inaccurate this just
looks really ugly it weakens
the queen side
but it's not
losing or anything right when you play
one d4
you got to be ready to play long games
so here's what we're going to do
we are going to
try to open the center
as quickly as we possibly can so let's
start by taking on d5
and finally completing our development
playing bishop g2 or continuing our
development rather i should say
and what strikes me about black's
position here is that black is quite
underdeveloped he's not castled
our pieces are extremely active knight
takes d5 this i was also not expecting
yeah this is just
this just looks really really shoddy
for black
now we have tactics here we can employ
to win a pawn
but i don't
think that that is necessarily the best
that we can do
i know some of you probably get are
getting excited about knight takes c6
but
then black gets a lot of development in
return for the pawn i'll show this more
after the game but i don't like knight
takes c6 it's like cashing in you know a
lottery ticket for for five bucks so
we've got
many many ways that we can handle
this position we can play e4
some of you see the movie for nothing
wrong with that but then i take c3 and
notice that the bishop guards f7 so
there's no mate on f7
but let's play it very simple let's play
bishop g2 let's develop our pieces
we can't go too wrong with
and approach
based purely on
development now we castle and we
might play e4 we might also not play e4
the problem in the movie 4 in
conjunction with bishop g2 is that it
blocks the bishop in that's not always
the greatest idea or at least we should
play e4 at a more opportune moment
in such positions there are many many
ways that we can nurture our advantage
we can play e4 now and we can also play
we can drop this knight back to c4
that's another possibility
i like the i like the look of e4 i think
we should play it now let's uh let's
let's let's clarify
matters
in the center
now i am
a a bit concerned
that
i was concerned not anymore that bishop
takes e5 here of course is a move
which damages
our structure but i feel intuitively
that we get a lot in return
for this trade we get potentially the d6
square which we could use as an outpost
for a rook we get the bishop pair and
overall our position is a lot more
active
so what i'd like to do now
is play the move b2b4 in order to
prevent c5 and what we need to prevent
at all costs is the knight the black
knight getting to d4 we cannot allow
that to happen
and that's why we play b4
queen c7 okay
we've got a lot of good ideas here a lot
of juicy sexy ideas one of them is just
to start advancing our pawn mass on the
king side but before we do that
again we should emphasize the completion
of development so let's go bishop e3 and
reinforce our control over the c5 square
if that makes sense
now we play f4 of course because the
pawn was hanging
and we do this with an eye
toward the subsequent idea of h3
followed by g4 which if black does not
react to it will trap the bishop with f5
now the other
interest that we have in
warding off the bishop is that we want
to get
a rook on that very very juicy square on
d6 so if we can remove the bishop from
h5 then we will have easier access to
the d file a5 okay so obviously here
well we have several moves we can even
play b5 but b5 gives up the c5 square i
wouldn't give the knight any unnecessary
scores i don't see a reason
i don't really see a reason not to play
a3 i mean
trades aren't the greatest thing here
for white
let me think about this for a hot second
yeah i'm not the biggest fan of trading
a5 is a really good move actually it's
better than it looks
okay let's go a3
let's go a3
there's a lot to think about here i i
might need to focus a little harder this
game this guy is clearly
a very very serious opponent
i'm not
totally thrilled about how i handled the
early part of the middle game but we're
definitely still better no question
about it one idea that worries me here
is that the bishop can evacuate via e2
the bishop can evacuate via e2 and then
park itself on b5
and then black and start pushing the
pawn majority with c5 and our light
squared bishop bothers me wow
okay
so
okay let's go ricky one will we have to
move
okay i actually think that black should
have traded a pair
of rooks because now this gives us
pretty easy access to the d6 square
which is what we're going to do
we are going to finally
get our rook onto d6
bang
and then we can double
and once the pressure on the d-file
reaches a zenith black could end up in
very serious trouble we also have
okay we obviously double here i'm
playing quickly but these moves are very
obvious
the move f5 is is also something to to
consider that just sort of turns the
pressure dial up on the king side
okay
i think in fact now is the perfect time
to turn up the dial
we can turn up the dial in several ways
f5 is not
the only way to do it we can also play
this weird looking with queen d4
in fact i think windy 4 is the best move
simply because what does this move
accomplish well first of all
we simply threatened to take the rook on
d7 right we have three attackers and
only two defenders it's a double attack
it's it's a simple double attack
because we're also attacking the b6 pawn
yeah no bishop takes b6 didn't work
because if queen takes b6 and that's a
check
oh but now we get this juicy pawn on d6
now we're making serious inroads
we still need to be careful black has
the a file that means there will be
counter play against our king
so we can't
fall asleep here but
now we're much better queen d8 passive
our opponent plays very very passively i
don't see a reason not to take this pawn
yeah this is this is uh
at this point i think we're winning if
we're careful
now should we take the queen
what do you guys think
should we take the queen
i just want to get a sense of what
people think just so i know how to
explain
so most of you are saying yes yeah
absolutely we should take the queen
absolutely
why not you're up a pawn you've got a
passer on d6 this wins the game very
easily
now here there is a very clinical move
that we can make
uh which is based on a rule that i've
shared many times which is that when
there is only one open file on the board
you generally want to make sure that you
are the one who controls it a lot of you
i guarantee are tempted by the move e5
but
e5 allows the blackrook to get to a8 and
get dibs on
the only open file we can play e5 later
if black plays e5 that's not bothering
us at all we can deploy this bishop to
h3 that only helps us
but this wins the game
in an elementary fashion we just drive
the rook up to a7 my guess is he's gonna
play king f7 which will be a blunder
but black is completely lost anyway
i mean the position just crumbles like a
house of cards
unless black defends
very very accurately here even then it's
lost king f8
okay
so the moment the move f6 was played
there's there's one thing that we
haven't done here yet which is which is
to find a job
for this bishop
we haven't found a job for this bishop
now we can we have bishop h3 and the job
for this bishop is to attack e6
bishop c4 seems forced but what has been
the consequence of the move bishop c4
well now the c6 pawn is undefended and
we use our
incredibly active rook
to harass that pawn as well and this
often happens when one side is really
passive you just start over extending
that side by attacking one weakness and
then another weakness and eventually
something is going to crumble knight b8
now what has been the effect of this
move well now the c5 square is
accessible to our bishop so we can play
either e5 or bishop c5
i think either move is
completely acceptable let's go bishop c5
this is a little bit more pure
i'm expecting e5 okay brooks c8 king g8
okay what's the fastest path to victory
here let's think for a second
e5 is very very tempting but maybe i
wouldn't necessarily play it
okay proposal
let's just bring our king up
let's just
bring our king up
good things are going to happen if we do
that patience patience when you're
converting these
let's keep going
h7 okay now we can keep going
now i think is the perfect time for e5
now that we have fully improved
the position of the game i have to
commend our opponent is defending like
like a line
making it hard
for us to convert but uh
okay it's only a matter of time
okay trade
trade and try on
push it back to d5
okay now
let us
reactivate the bishop and move it out to
d3
i think the bishop has done its job
i think now it's time for us to
seek greener pastures
and let's blow this thing open with b5
this is the power of bringing our king
to d4 look at how much work the king is
doing it's protecting e5 it's protecting
c5
and now the floodgates finally open we
force the knight back and we can push
our d-pawn and win a piece
now there's details here that i can
explain after the game but
finally the game is over we push
and look at how
we have like a symphony of pieces here
king f7
what move is absolutely critical to play
after king f7 otherwise it's actually a
draw
critical detail
avoid the temptation to play rook c8
because black plays king e7 it's still
winning but this is so much easier
because we block the black king from
approaching the pawn and rook c8 becomes
finally unstoppable
and if black moves the rook from da we
can promote directly noticing the
x-ray against the black king
there we go
yeah the king is a total giga chad this
game
yeah
good stuff
okay i will say straight away for the
engine andy's definitely not the
greatest quality middle game i think i
made some inaccuracies but
still
pretty good game overall
okay
so
this is this love
now the slav
has been around since the dawn of time
and it it has only preceded in in
popularity by the queen's gamma decline
which is what people played
basically since modern chess was
invented
a little historical detour so the first
time i'm seeing c6 in the database
is 1837.
so steinitz was one of the first people
to play it lasker played it this guy
shallop who developed a lot of modern
opening theory and after knight f3
knight f6 knight c3
originally when people were first
playing this they they played let's see
they played either d take c4 or e6 which
are the modern moves
a6 was first played
in 1929 by sultan khan
who was a very famous character
he was you should read about him
sultan khan played a six for the first
time in 1929
and then this guy alater who was
i am
so it's named after chabanenko who was a
soviet trainer but i don't actually
think chabanenko he was not nearly the
first to play a6
yeah sultan khan is super fascinating
so
e6
is the semi slav d takes c4 is the
traditional slav
and a6 is the chebanenko these are the
big three
and we decided on the move g3 here black
plays bishop g4 which is to my knowledge
not a move the main move here is dtx4
transposing into
the g3 semi-slot generally what tends to
happen here
is that black will play e6 at some point
and you will get a direct transposition
to the g3 variation
of the semi-slot which i actually played
in the first round of the us open by the
way i played the g3 semi-slav my
opponent made a mistake pretty quickly
here d take c4 is the topical move
and you get you get a very very complex
position b5 castles bishop b7 and now i
like the movie iv etc etc yeah it is
yeah of course it bears
massive similarities to the catalan
you know with the fiance bishop the
arrangement of black pawns it's similar
to the catalan
you can do your own research here i
don't want to dwell
too much on the opening phase but bishop
g4 walks right into 95
and after bishop h5
queen b3 already applies very very
serious pressure on
black center and on black's queen side
so
i want to show you what my idea was
after b5
so after b5
i wanted to take on d5
this is more accurate than taking on b5
because here black can actually take
with the a pawn
and here you're not really giving black
any extra options because knight takes
d5
kind of like what our opponent plate is
is
clearly bad
and after c takes d5 we blast open the
center
very very quickly we go bishop g2
and after e6 my idea was to play e4
trying to exploit the fact that black's
development is is
very very dubious
this leads to interesting complications
if black just takes on e4
a position like this strikes me as
just really really good for white rook
a7 maybe the other bishop comes out and
x-rays the rook
you can see the disparity in peace
activity
that's one way to handle the position
but even if we play this
more placidly and we just castle
there's no question that white is
slightly better
um so b6 is
obviously worse he takes d5
and now especially cd5 bishop g2 and e4
would have been even stronger probably
than in the other line
the rook was hanging david
what's wrong with b4 in those types of
positions
no
b you mean b4 here
now here i think white has he takes d5
temporary knight sack but this is
totally destructive i mean i'm just
coming at you from all sides here
queen a4 is also a threat
this looks devastating
so b6 cd5995
okay we developed with bishop g2 yeah a
lot of people would play knight c6
and this is like the classic
concept of like seeing a cool tactic
and
getting carried away with it like
letting the cool factor
influence
your perception of the position because
you actually have to you can't just say
oh knight c6 wins upon that's it it's
not the end of the line black plays
knight takes c6
and if you force yourself to calculate
one move deeper you immediately begin to
see
that
this line contains serious problems
because after knight takes d5
for one thing black has knight takes d4
but even if black plays a move
no knight takes d4 actually is
i think the issue with knight takes d5
if you play queen takes d5 there is
still knight takes d4
queen takes h5 gets checkmated knight c2
so
when you see a cool resource you have to
force yourself to calculate a little bit
a little bit deeper than that
castles bishop d6
okay so we played e4
maybe not the best move
um maybe not the best move
i'm thinking now that it might have been
a good idea
to move the knight back to c4 to to to
not allow the idea that our opponent
implemented in the game with bishop
takes c5 so this would have forced the
bishop back to c7 and i'm thinking that
e4 now looks really really good
and just look at this position white is
in
tremendous shape here
we've got this potential idea of pushing
d5
black's got weaknesses on the queen side
it's a it's a bad position probably like
point seven or point eight would be my
guess
knight takes e4 queen a4 check
where are you talk oh you mean in the
knight takes e6 line
yeah queen a4 check but there's knight
b5
it's it's and maybe e4 i was calculating
this and i wasn't sure what to make of
it
but it's unnecessary because we're just
you know sometimes it's unnecessary to
seek these complications when you're
just better positionally
you know you take the less risky
approach so e4
we trade
we trade
and this is a very interesting position
conceptually that there there is a lot
going on here
um and and
just
spending time analyzing positions with
imbalances i think is is one
easy way to get better at positional
chess
because
from a tactical standpoint this position
is pretty peaceful
there aren't there isn't that much
potential for
sacrifices or attacks both kings are
safe for the time being
um
so
you know one way that you approach such
positions is
you take the sort of
uh
approach of understanding how to
position your pieces
and optimize them and then how to
prevent your opponent from optimizing
his or her pieces
and
that is how i came up with the idea of
b4 because
i asked myself where is black going to
put
his knight well probably not d7 knight
d7 doesn't look impressive
so
then i realized that if we just sort of
go about our business
black's going to go c5 and then knight
c6 and the knight is going to have
access to this very nasty outpost on d4
so
no i i prefer not to have the eval bar
during analysis just to promote a more
sort of more learning
so that's why i played b4
classic prophylaxis to prevent c5
yeah knight d7 also gives up the pawn on
c6 that's true so queen c7
um
now we develop our bishop
what if he plays a5 now yeah to be
honest i missed like i forgot that a5
was a thing
probably a5 we would still play a3
i don't think anything changes here
a b a b
or k one queen a one now you could argue
that maybe the trade is in black's favor
this leads to a similar position uh
then the game
to the game so queen c7 bishop e3 knight
d7 f4
and a5 was very very good
because the interesting subtlety here is
that if black plays a normal move like
if black plays rook fda
then
what would we play here with white those
of you who paid attention
during the game should
basically know what move i was planning
yes h3 very good
so again this sets up the idea of g4 and
the subtlety here is that bishop e2 may
seem
like it evacuates the bishop just in
time but
after bishop b5 you have a4 trapping the
bishop
and the power of the move a5 is that it
forces by forcing a3
by trading on b4 you are now giving
yourself this beautiful b5 square white
no longer has a4
um so this was very well played by our
opponent
but
to me it would have been a better idea
to take on a one here first
um which piece would we have taken with
probably the queen
why the queen in order to because the
rook has a very clear role and the
rook's role is to occupy the d6 square
but i think the way to play this with
black would have been to very quickly
focus on creating a past pawn to counter
balance the effect of us putting a rook
on d6
why didn't you trade bishops with bishop
f1
so i'm assuming you're asking here why
didn't i play bishop bishop f1 was very
much possible that's a totally
legit candidate move but i thought that
the bishop had a lot of potential energy
i felt like at some point we would
weaken the e6 pawn and the bishop could
move on to h3 which is what happened but
absolutely bishop f1 is totally viable
i guess black takes and goes c5 though
and with every piece that goes off the
board black's position becomes easier to
defend
um
so we played rook ad one
and a lot of people i think would
hesitate to play this movie because it
gives up the a file but remember
here there are two open files and they
kind of
cancel each other out and you can also
ask yourself well what's going on on the
a file not much the only thing that
black can do is put a rook on a2 and
somebody during the game asked me
if i was scared of this move no because
it doesn't accomplish anything on its
own the rook is an annoyance it's an
irritant but it doesn't create any
threats we can go about our business we
can play rook d6 and our pressure down
the d file is going to be a lot more
significant because there's actually
stuff going on on the d file there's a
knight there and if the knight moves
then the pawn becomes weak etc we have
f5
so
rook fd8 rook d6 and this is where our
opponent started to crumble
i think already at this point black is
much worse
he probably had to go c5 this was the
last chance to do it
what would we do here with white so one
move is rook
ed1
um
yeah we would probably probably play
rookie d1 for starters
and then we would push the f button to
f5 and i feel like the pressure gets
basically overwhelming here
yeah f5 is coming next
or the immediate f5
so knight f8 rookie d1
and now queen d4 is very accurate
attacking the rook attacking the pawn
after rook takes d6 basically the game
is over
so
here very important moment occupying the
only open file or k1
getting the rook active
maximally active
deploying the bishop
rook c7 attacking the pawn weakened by
black's last move
and overextending black completely
and this is an interesting moment so
king f2 probably not the top computer
move i'm sure there's there's probably
some sort of
um some sort of more immediate win i'm
actually curious what the top computer
movie is here
let's take a look
maybe it is king f2 sometimes it is
you know those slow moves can be
actually the best move in the position
yeah b4 is very bad apparently
oh it's plus two here
at b4 it doesn't like at all
before it doesn't like it all just wants
us to play
f3 and cut off the bishop
so b4 doesn't like
and it's because of a5 yeah so you guys
actually were right it is because of a5
this i forgot about this move
this is a very very annoying move
and it's showing that white is still
slightly better but
yeah v4 was done
yeah so even here it's not that bad for
black
this is a mistake
yeah and then queen a7 was still was
still maybe a chance
black could have defended better but
yeah it's good i mean it's plus seven
you could also play rookie seven and go
after the pawn
but king f2 is the second move as you
can see
so
this slow approach is wildly effective
yeah and this is just really easy
okay very good
so that is that a pretty pretty nice
technical game
[Music]